welcome to this video yeah this is some
video about two games I play dumb yeah
just the last weekend so yesterday and
the day before one was played in the
Dutch league and the other one was
played in the German league I always get
requests to to show my over the board
game so um yeah i'll show the games at
least them the two critical moments and
this erm yeah these games really show
that sometimes just um one position one
critical moment can decide the game um
yeah the first game he is from the Dutch
league played him on Saturday so what
was the first of the two games and we
see here the position on move 39 I just
that took the pawn on e5 with my queen
and like now played rook to f6 attacking
the bishop ok let's have a look at this
position why disappoint up I've got five
pawns and blacks got four so I 1 upon
essentially the e5 pawn was was just
taken but the position is of course very
concrete there are passed pawns the
default for white the B point for black
and also the apron which is the
long-term asset in the short run the
deep onus of course am quite quite
dangerous force but um a main issue in
this game is that this Bishop is so much
stronger than this night which is
limited by the porn on g3 the night time
really doesn't help much black also has
a weak King his pawn cover is somewhat
stripped but not in all this is a very
concrete position like a text this
Bishop and the very important point
about this position is that my opponent
was down to 24 seconds exactly 24 and I
had more than 30 minutes
left and it's move 40 so i am just need
to make one move to get them together
the child control completed um and also
he of course but he's only got 24
seconds so my goal was to make a move
that said some young some concrete
problem from maybe even some trap if
possible so that he's got problems to
make the correct move and this is 24
seconds so I didn't want to invest so
much time so that he can think on my
time but in fact in this position I had
some a very strong move available which
I only am young saw and I'm not so much
shown to me by the computer and if you
have some time on your hands and then
try to calculate this position White has
a very strong move if you find it it
would be it would be very good and
because it's really am somewhat
counterintuitive muth in fact um White
has got two strong moves here but I
played the none of them I played them a
plate and Bruce move which in fact won
the game because it it had been very
good oops I need to switch this off it
had a very good good point to it what I
played ok I first I'll show you the best
move um so if you want to think further
pause the video the best move in this
position is in fact the quite stunning
move rook f1 which is is really really
strong the idea is that it's the yes
sort of prophylactically covers f2 so
that after rook takes f5 white can play
d6 and now we'll promote the pawn
there's no way for black to stop the
porn from promoting he cannot do
anything against this the the rooks are
placed in such an unlucky ways that that
there's no way to stop the porn if black
tries this move
too yeah sort of provoke right into
taking then White has the very strong
move Queen c7 and black can resign the
pond simply promotes ruka have one is
extremely strong I didn't I didn't think
of this at all I mean I sort of noticed
that the pawn is hard to stop but I
really am didn't ya this didn't cross my
mind at all look everyone there's
another strong move which I which I saw
but I didn't really understand right is
strong to be honest d 6 is another
strong move them that I also considered
the problem is of course this this
Bishop is a mean and like will take on
f2 if I just if I if I take here it's um
it just collapses on f 2 this is just
the problem like will take here and then
the F poorness is hanging multiple times
and black is even better in this
position so this doesn't help but what i
can do is i can play i can play d 6
which is which is strong and saw this
but rook t6 after this i only thought
about the the endgame of course white
can take here take him and grab here and
he will will end up with an extra porn
in the rook endgame I'm in fact like as
in this move which is probably stronger
with counter play but this was enough to
convince me that I shouldn't play this
because quite simply m this this kind of
stuff it's just the draw three against
two no way to win this against our
decent defense I saw this and oh ki
sabji success isn't so great but in fact
d6 is strong d 6 36 and here White has a
strong move for each form which I didn't
think of the problem is that ok this t6
just
just drove the rook away so that this is
not threatened he cannot return because
of rope the aid winning the Queen and
this is ya problem white just threatens
h5 to destabilize a five and probably
yeah probably this is serve is not not
not a defensible position at least it's
very very tricky to play yeah this is
also strong um yeah the thing is after I
looked at this about two or three
minutes I saw I saw another interesting
move which are played I played rook to
be one and the idea behind this move was
that I saw that like now can can draw
with with rook t2 but then my idea was
that it maybe it's not able to to work
this out in 24 seconds and instead
choose to take on b1 because there's a
known tendency then if you have you have
very much a very very little time then
you often opt for simple moves like
taking pieces exchanging or giving
checks and this is another case I just
hoped that you couldn't couldn't really
work out if root d2 or something is a
good move after all if you look at this
this is the best move this pawn is now
hanging in two ways of course this is
also hanging but I was hoping that he
couldn't work this out in fact this this
probably draws the line that I saw was a
bishop takes g6 F takes g6 Queen to b4
and now I'm rook here and this should I
know this was this was really three or
four would when I did here Brooke before
before of course black needs to check
first take take and take him and and
this is of course cause a draw
with with what perpetual checks no way
to to escape this as white and this was
the land that I saw so it was sort of a
drawing head gamble um but ok I only had
this 23 24 seconds and he let it run
down to four seconds at the end and then
then took him probably simply because he
couldn't work out in this 20 seconds of
route d2i to rook a to a similar really
would draw and now i have just Bishop
takes be one and this position is
winning for white I still have my extra
porn and he doesn't have any meaningful
attack on f2 simply this active rook is
gone and he has no way to bring the
Queen into a position where it can
attack him f2 and after this it's um get
just a matter of decent technical play
which I managed unfortunately Queen to
be eight and what about i forgot to
mention my opponent here evoked the
Grutter he's some playoff strong feeder
mask of the strength of God 2340 rating
so just to put it in perspective he's a
pretty good player played him last year
also and then the leak and I a made a
draw but that was in huge trouble he
could have easily won this game I think
so um yeah it was nice to have for such
a good position ok I played I'm coming
to c5 to get the the a porn mobile III
and rook Bishop d3 which is strong when
do I want to put the bishop on b5 so
that it may be even on c6 so that it
covers the pawns and on b5 it also helps
to isolate this b poole so that i can
pick it up
this is a pretty pretty simple procedure
now Pusha p.m. and e2 and droopy one I
just I just kept the porn he just tried
to the last yeah last bullet here to get
some counter play before Queen deform
and time I grabbed the porn I only need
to be a bit cautious now at this moment
as Knight f3 check and maybe rook h6 can
be some counter play and in fact the the
cleanest win now is the tactical move t6
which I didn't really really appreciate
and I calculated this but i forgot that
after Queen takes I just saw that this
move is not working as the rook is
protected by the night but in fact I can
play a 5 and this is winning as the rook
now needs to go on an unprotected square
let's say moo here and and this is
winning so d6 was what's the quicker win
what I played was the safe move Queen to
see one which covers the age 6 square so
that the rook cannot cannot swing over
and he played tried down the check and
I've formed so the last kind of counter
play Madame here I'm not made on h2 I
have this this was too quick I'm not I'm
not made on h2 I can just play age 3
enter and escape with the King and at
the end of all this I still have the
above the to pass points and then yea
the deep on just just decided this issue
king here and associate it's now that I
think of it it it's quite funny if you
have a look at the second game it was a
just rather similar didn't really notice
a hint it up to now okay so at the end
he cannot do anything against the pawn
promotion
um yeah pretty good to finish it really
a remarkable movers this this rook f1
which is which is really strong in this
position and which I didn't didn't spot
I mean my rupee one was the clever move
you know from from a practical point of
view but it was not the best move by
farm okay this was the first game and
the second game was just a plate one day
later in the german league so this is
the position after mover 31 by white
which is me and played white again and i
just took on f form and we captured a
queen queens right on it for my opponent
down oops i just saw that the board is
screwed up I'm sorry ok this should be
fine now I'm sorry I just need to adjust
this ok I'm take a look at the position
I just took on f4 that was a queen trade
on f4 and yeah you notice that White's
pawn structure my pawn structure is a
bit bitter acteon the King side which is
unfortunate but I've got two extra pawns
the deep on here on d5 and yet another
extra porn is the beep on which doesn't
look too impressive admittedly it's
black black smooth now and in this
position which is really the critical
position of this game he played the move
rookie age now in this position please
take a look and try to work out what
what white should play here stay silent
for a couple of seconds that you can
stop the video if you like yeah in fact
them why did this position has some a
winning move already straight straight
out wins the game
and this is Luke takes b5 the exchange
sacrifice 8x b5 and now Wyatt has got
tubes the White has got to connect add 2
pi spawns which is supported by the rook
and by the bishop and justice is too
much I'll show at them I'll show what
happened further but I wanted to show
what black should play in this position
he absolutely needs to capture on B to
the problem was that my opponent here
frankly fed is about to 150 rated um
that that him that he didn't like this
position which is understandable white
white is better in this position but the
problem is that simply am the
alternative what he played just lost the
game outright so um he needs to he need
to play this no matter what they're
simply simply no I'm no alternative the
the problem is in this position it will
lead to a bedrock endgame for example
rook da truck t1 yeah probably root d 6
i'm not sure but at the end there will
be an endgame of this type which is
better for white maybe winning but it's
a it's still a rook endgame so black has
chances to fight and in the game there
was no chance at all to save it this may
be losses but it's a fight rook endgame
always has a very big drawing margin so
you always have some chances to to maybe
save it
okay um in the game as mentioned he
played rookie 8 and then I could
sacrifice the exchange which I did and
now I made a pretty typical mistake at
least there for me if I see a
continuation that I'm belief is winning
or is a very huge advantage then I am
very often simply play those moves
instantly I mean if I kept calculated a
line let's say I as I invested five
minutes and I calculate the line then I
just play out the line move by move and
don't really look at look at
alternatives in fact in this position I
played the move a six which is some
which it wins the game at the end but
here I had had a simpler continuation in
fact the most d6 some is winning
somewhat quicker I said immediately
takes them a 8 into and under control
and this makes the a porn yeah much more
dangerous yeah how should like try to
defend probably rookie too so relatively
best move I'm then I just play a six
routine six and under a seven yeah
there's no way to save this I mean you
can try to attack the pawns but it
doesn't doesn't really help I can win
the temple with them Bishop to c 6 and
then promote yeah white um will win this
pretty easily i get b 5 and also have
some ideas to play against f7 so this
sermon basically I'm just converts the
the two pawns into an extra piece so it
winds pretty easily what I saw is the
following line I can it exactly happened
in this game I saw a six and it also
wins but the other one was just quicker
I saw this DC
Rukia d7 it's completely forced now
rookie 2 and Bishop c6 in fact i
calculated up to this move and just
concluded that white should be winning
those two pawns are too much and also
note the similarity the bishop won't be
five protecting the d7 phone was just
the same the day before this is quite
uncanny ok so I'm what what could them
could to black do yeah he tried to yeah
use the king but the problem is I have
all the time in the world to just take
the bleep on he tried to keep it for one
move but then I could take it yep like
black simply has no defense i have her
various ways to to win now let's say use
the B porn yeah now it's Luke c8 the
same winning move that won the day
before and said the threat and now I'm
yeah and so it's it's a multitude term
off wins but I can just play games you
to strengthening the position a bit and
now I'm threatening a 7 i'm in fact if
you look at this some a 7 move this
looked good here even a seven but the
problem was that he has check and rook
here and we'll pick up is heaven um this
way so it's not not the cleanest way to
win but Kings you to what I played just
threatens a seven and he has no way to
deal with that plate at 587 young and
now I from if black takes the poor then
I'll I get a new queen and yeah and with
the next row Bishop and extra porn so we
cannot take it but I'm also threatening
rook c8 so he went here
rook c8 and after this he resigned so
it's the same absolutely the same you
should be up on Yelp c8 and resins just
the same as in the game the day before I
only noticed this this this now amazing
that I didn't didn't realize it during
the game all right so we see also here
one critical moment decided to game with
the rook takes be two in this position
he could have this position this
position with rook takes me to I could
have put up some much yeah more serious
resistance and the lower group takes me
five basically lost the game and this is
actually I find it pretty pretty
surprising that he didn't take this into
account because it's something that you
always need to think of is if there's an
advanced a porn like this on a five and
you've got this is bishop on g2 it's
just the same with the bishop on g7 an
opponent a form then this combination
the the the rook pawn and the bishop is
always always very very dangerous and
you always need to take ideas into
account to free the pawn to you have to
make the home run if you want to call it
take on it like that so route cakes b5
was the first move that I even saw this
rook takes b5 idea like four or five
moves ago that this is threatening and I
was really a quite surprised that it
didn't to take on be too because simply
of this rook takes b5 had yet is just
forced I mean it's not the matter of
getting a pawn but you need to cover b5
because this exchange seconds friend
yeah I hope you enjoyed those two
fragments I didn't want to show the
whole games then this would be an hour
long video and frankly speaking most of
them most of the stuff before wasn't so
interesting yeah I hope you enjoyed it
and I'll be back soon with I guess a new
eps
from the modern classic series which is
also I think a popular one I hope you
look forward to that yeah cheers and bye